[Music]
there are very few occupations that are
better on a rowboat and when listing the
jobs lessened by listing odd lists
artists as least on the last listing
list Jesus is his pencil made of hopes
and dreams how else would it sink down
into oblivion so quickly you have just
hidden and the first lesson of the sea
always being a spare pencil this is
actually the second lesson of the sea
the first lesson of the sea is never
trust a nice old lady when there is a
giant diamond involved this is not how's
work underwater or above water or beside
water Patrick how come you always do pay
pay better question if Patrick always
blows paper on why would you create
anything other than scissors its
jellyfish look you knew what you were
getting into when you asked me to send
this so now I have to be the one to say
you can't use a pencil to draw clear
lines on the sand at the bottom of the
ocean I know the truth hurts but you
were the one who got us into the
situation oh you need is a fall hanim
this isn't close to a full head of hair
and given Squidward's constant state of
grump there was no way he'd be this
excited about one sixteenth of his head
having hair each work of art is like a
child and must be treated as such
Jesus Banksy just got real dark I'm
going to town so imitation sponge knob
is sentient enough to understand the
plan is to go knock on Squidward's door
but not sentient enough to know how to
form words even spongebob can't erase
the classic how does he not hear this
sip or you could when I do not mean to
sound like a broken record here swim the
drawings have all been two-dimensional
so how did this bowling ball become
three-dimensional unroll maybe it added
the single dimension from this clearly
one-dimensional show when pinhead
Patrick gets bowled over he clearly only
splits into seven pins so the strike is
alive don't agree spare me you know who
doesn't think non sequiturs are funny I
once saw a duck with a third bill that's
who whose booth bulgy eyes
that Square buddy this to buckteeth and
it's stupid toy looks good you spongebob
with best friends like this who needs
anemones sheezus chuckling christ
almighty that doodle cuss is like a
goddamn sailor shameful the villain
isn't really dead as he's only been
disarmed cliche the arm approaches
SpongeBob's home with two stories but as
it enters the home suddenly there are
three stories and I'd be content with
just one coherent story suddenly the
pencil eraser can erase more than
doodles and if that is the case this
Boulder should have been eviscerated
earlier my only question about Sponge
bucks Square ass here is why does he
have two buttholes and why are they
located on his right cheek oh my god is
he covered in bottles and so now the
magic pencil can draw color as well I'm
beginning to think this magic pencil is
putting too much emphasis on the magic
part and not enough emphasis on the dear
God are we still sitting in the logic of
Spongebob part okay fine that's magic
why would the pencil need to be pieced
back together when it already had
magically grown back to its normal size
and the doodle fight also the dick cut
off the second pencil sharpened part
that is so disappointing
you keep your pencil in your pocket you
know what I mean
make sure you click that Bell icon but
clicking the little bell icon is how you
make sure you get notified every time we
release a video so click it well well
what is this sacrebleu
what you drawn where you know my name is
Simon and I like to do rings Squidward
if you had some hair you'd be the most
gorgeous creature and I save I'm good
enough I'm smart enough and doggone it
people like me I am a god you dull
creature and I will not be bullied by
any last words last words let's see
how's the food
get me the [ __ ] out of it yeah how's
that for last words how they don't
you've just been erased
[Music]
oh yeah